hey man it's me kevin smith and welcome
to masters of the universe revelation
celebration here i'm going to provide
commentary tracks for the first five
episodes
of masters of the universe of revelation
that concentrate
on the writers we're celebrating the
writers of this show now i didn't do it
alone i came up with the story and
whatnot but everybody
took a script and so throughout this
mini series
we're going to sit down with every
writer of each episode
and do a commentary track so hopefully
you've already watched
masters of the universe of revelation
now on netflix it dropped july
23rd watch them all then go back
and watch him with this commentary track
if you want to find out
a little bit more about how we got to
where we got to okay so
for the first episode um i'm gonna be
going solo mish because i was
the the only writer uh and so other
episodes i'll be here
interviewing uh the other writers so
it'll be me
and and uh dia me and mark me and tim
and then me and eric but for episode one
is you're just stuck with
me uh so before we get going
um i've told the story many times but
just to keep it all in one place
mattel asked to meet with me they had
some project super secret project they
wanted to talk about
i said mattel like where do i gotta go
and they were like
else gundog i was like what that's too
far i ain't going man i don't want to
talk to mattel
and then rob david thank god i was like
we'll come to him we'll go to his house
and so they made me sign an nda
non-disclosure agreement
and then rob when he came over was like
we're thinking about
you for this he-man and the masters of
the universe thing
that we're doing and i was like oh how
interesting i was like i watched every
episode of that cartoon
in the 80s i told rob i was like mostly
hate watched it because you know i was
like they never stab each other
you know i was 13 when i was watching it
so like i was kind of like this is for
babies but i watched every episode
because we didn't have cable tv back
then you just watched what was on tv
so i was like i'm way familiar overly
familiar with the mythology
considering i never had the toys there's
another reason why like i never took it
into my
heart because i didn't have the toys my
parents were like you're not getting
another toy we spent so much money on
star wars toys now you're not gonna play
with those
like i was already stopping playing with
action figures and stuff they're like no
no masters of nothing for you so i
didn't have the toys to bond with but i
knew
the episodes very very well because you
know they put them on high rotation and
whatnot and i'd watch them after school
so i said well i said yeah you know i
i guess like let me think about this let
me put it through my brain pan think
about it for a day or two
and i did and i came up with a story and
so i was like rob i got a story
you want to you want to hear it and told
rob's story he's like that's dope man
he's going like all right so like now
we just tell netflix that story and i
was like oh we gotta pitch this to
netflix i was like i'll tell you right
now
netflix never bought anything i ever
made so like
you know i've been in their pitch six
times they're very nice but they never
buy anything so you know i'm not gonna
be much help there
and rob was like oh this is already sold
netflix already bought it
and i was like what it's already a show
like this show is gonna happen
with or without me so you know i was
like great yeah i'll jump on the story
train yeah i'm happy to do that
and so uh that i i pitched you know
this the story i told rob i then told
teddy biasely who was our boss at
netflix and between those two towers
uh between uh uh rob teddy
and me there's three towers of paternia
that's how we came to masters of the
universe
uh revelation so
teddy as an exec at a company never had
an experience
like this it has forgotten more about
masters of the universe than you'll ever
know world's biggest motu fan has every
figure his own figures from childhood
set up in his house and whatnot rob
you know runs the mattel uh television
you know
uh division uh he's a story man
he wrote like masters universe comics
for dc comics for the last few years
so between those two cats man i was like
oh my god we're infallible like
they'll never let me go off the track
they'll never let me not let it be
what it was and what it needs to be
and what it needed to be was what teddy
wanted teddy had this idea
to do a very serious handling of
masters of the universe he's like i
loved that show when i was growing up
every episode i thought he-man was gonna
get killed by skeletor he's like and
it didn't happen i was so relieved he's
like then i got older and i realized
they didn't even punch each other like
that was never going to happen they
never closed class
swords like you know he realized there
were no stakes he was like so i always
dreamed of doing a masters in the
universe and not even doing he was like
i dreamed they would do
massive universe like very serious very
like grown up
and so i was like all right like i'm
your guy i could i could totally do that
if you wanted me to reinvent it
i'm not your guy but you want me to just
keep going with it like that's what i
did with daredevil green arrow my comic
book runs
and that's how i got the job too rob was
like i loved your daredevil and green
arrow run so i felt like my god if you
could do
that with somebody else's characters you
might be able to do that with these
characters
and i absolutely fell in love with all
these characters man like uh
he-man in many ways for me was not a
superhero
because he was more like he was based on
conan and stuff so he was more a figure
of science fiction fantasy
but you know once you get into the lore
you realize thanks to dc comics who
wrote masters the universe for quite a
few years
they created a lot of the backstory and
lore including the secret identity of
prince adam
that people didn't know about some
people some people knew and some people
didn't know
that came from the world of comic books
so put through that prism i was like oh
he-man
is superman but he just don't wear the
suit he just goes nipple out man which
in many ways is much bolder
for a superhero so i
dove in and uh i wrote uh an outline
for a 10 episode series called masters
of the universe colon
the end of the universe and we that was
the working title for
like two three months and then teddy was
just like
we don't want to give it away in the
title he's like let's just make it
nebulous and stuff and he's like you
know at the end of the day
a lot of stuff going to be revealed here
so revelation
you liked it so uh here we go man we're
going to
watch uh masters of the universe uh
revelation episode one
written by yours truly um and i'm gonna
do commentary track on it right here for
you so
everybody line it all up let's see
uh uh uh ready to press play
on the count of one two
three press play uh this
logo um which you know
if you look at it is based on the old
mattel
artwork of the cards the whole idea of
the opening
credit sequence here um or title
sequence
was about using the mattel classic
mattel artwork because you know they've
got
all this boris vallejo looking artwork
in their library and stuff and so i was
like let's use that
you know like that the cool way to
highlight that this is
about the toys this is not a technically
a sequel to filmation that's why i was
always like it's a spiritual sequel
to the legacy series to the filmation
series because the
filmation series is owned by somebody
completely different i think universal
owns that library
so all of what we do is based on masters
of the universe and
the property as owned by mattel they
created a lot of the backstory with the
mini comics
many comics were led to the dc comics so
this opening sequence i remember
writing this like i wrote all those
words
um and then bounced them off rob and i
was like what about this what about this
um knowing that liam cunningham was
going to
read it and oh my god he shreds it
sometimes i just
smoke weed and watch that over and over
again just the opening credit secrets
look at my name
my name shows up right when strider's
foot comes down
um i was so excited when i saw that um
the uh this play written by kevin smith
look at that this plays exactly as i
wrote
directed by adam connor adam adam and
pat
let me just take a moment to shout out
adam and pat there are directors
i consider them co-writers as well story
people through and through man
so much so that when we got to like
episode 10 they were remembering things
that we had done as writers in episode
one that they wanted to pay off
so you know chef's kiss to them
particularly any action sequence you see
they took minor words on the page and
made it utterly dynamic the boys
are absolutely brilliant they poured
their hearts into this
adam was like look i didn't grow up with
this but i come to love this very deeply
and he knows this [ __ ]
inside and out now both of the boys they
know their deep
motu mythology okay so the idea here
was to uh pick up some strands that were
left
from the old filmation uh show the
chiefly being um somebody
is related to somebody else that's all
i'll say
and so that's is kind of what we're
going with
uh also what you know the what if uh
possibility of what would happen
if the one person who didn't know
he-man's secret you know
found out and found out in the worst
possible way
um as you can see from this beginning
it's a real bait and switch
um because hopefully you're watching
this you've already watched it
uh you know that's he-man but it ain't
he-man and if you know your figures
you know who it's going to be first
appearance of our sorceress version of
the sorceress as voiced by
the the great susan eisenberg the the
voice of calm
as wonder woman in the dc universe and
in in
life in general i always tell her i was
like god you it must be amazing
to like listen to your voice you could
read me to sleep and she got this calm
soothing voice
um teddy was the first person to point
out like like this scene took place
outside of grayskull and he's like she
can't
go off grayskull property you know
only in falcon form bird form she can't
go out as the sorceress
so everything had to take place on the
jaw bridge which i was like
that ain't no punishment setting
something on the jaw bridge man
a minimum the great mark camel uh
playing our skeletor that was my
favorite moment
of skull tours in one of my favorite
moments there's more to come but
when he doesn't even get out his opening
line skeleton and he just gets knocked
out and
so the idea there's steven root as
cringer
uh liam cunningham is playing our man at
arms griffin newman plays
orco and he is fantastic they're all
great the entire cast steven root
is playing our cringer of course and
sarah michelle gellar is playing
artilla um chris wood is the voice the
guy we're about to meet very soon prince
adam also the voice
of he-man a lot of these cats i've
worked with before
dedrick bader um who plays king randor
i've worked with
uh on jay and son of bob's truck back
and jane salam bob reboot
um uh let's see griffin i'd never worked
with before he lobbied to get the job
on on twitter man and he got and he was
perfect for it he was so passionate
about steven rude i've worked with
many times so i thought he'd be
fantastic as cringer chris wood i've
worked with
a couple times first time of course
being on supergirl where he played monel
um so you know i tend to do that i tend
to rework with a lot of people i've
worked with before mark hamill
uh i worked with as well on jay and
silent bob schrickback
so the idea behind the first like let's
say 10 minutes of this episode
was to give you the exact masters of the
universe that you
remember although if you go back and
watch it
you know i'm not saying like we're
better but we
are but we get to be better because we
weren't making a children's cartoon
that was all about teaching lessons and
and not showing fighting
we get to play as adult i referred to
this as adult animation for the last two
years
until i watched uh robert kirkman's
invincible
and then i was like we're not adult at
all we're a kiddie show
by comparison i mean they put a human
being through a train like
many human beings like it was kind of
nuts so you know it's
adult themes you know uh there's no sex
you know if you're like i can't wait to
see him [ __ ] you're out of luck
there's no sex uh in in eternia
uh particularly our version of it and
stuff it's a high adventure tale
that begins very simply as you know what
could be a standard issue
adventure from the 80s in terms of like
skeletor wants grace gold he shows up
with you know
the shaping staff and tricks the
sorceress but she can't be tricked
because
she does it so it's it's skeletor but
she wasn't expecting faker and
so that's where we stand right now the
same old same old and
she says in the in the episode as she
did in the teaser that everyone saw
uh time after time you try to take this
castle
you know it's meant to be like we've
been here before as you see
we introduce every character and they
get their showcase you know like
evil in the magic of evelyn
and lena heady takes the stage she is
amazing watch her performance it's it's
track it through these first five
because it becomes very important
for the back five as well um so everyone
gets to
you know we essentially the idea behind
it
it was you know we knew people
who were going to watch this the
audience it was made for teddy wanted to
make a show
at netflix and rob wanted to make a show
at mattel television
that catered to the people that watched
the original cartoon and collected the
toys
the other show they're doing he-man the
masters of the universe is more a
kid-oriented kind of
cg reinvention of the show
and the movie is going to be whatever
the movie's going to be when they
eventually make it but both of the boys
rob
and and uh and teddy were like this
is essentially for us like that's what
teddy was like i just want to make the
thing i've always wanted to see my whole
life
i want to make sure that that audience
is fed and mattel naturally was very
into that idea because it's like that'll
help us sell toys for heaven sakes
so boom that's how revelation came to be
so the opening is meant to play like you
know look
everything you remember is absolutely
true cringer's still chicken [ __ ]
orco is still a little [ __ ] up you know
uh no
some people know that prince adam is he
man other people don't tila clearly does
not
uh tila gets to step up you know you
hear a bit about her backstory and
whatnot
she's not she refers to herself as an
orphan girl she doesn't quite know
who her mom is
um so as we go into our story
things are exactly as they should be the
idea
i said in the writer's room the idea is
the audience is going to come to watch
this
the audience it's made for we want it to
feel like
hey man your toys are exactly where you
left them
and they're still doing the same exact
things
and now you just get to play with them
as a grown-up i love this moment
this i love this one listen to the mark
hamill
in the background i like his dope when
he kind of gets the spell where he's
hearing from the sorcerers
originally in the script it was going to
be him being contacted by the spirit of
grayskull
but uh instead i was like you know what
it's the sorceress and the saucers plays
a big part
in our series so i was like you know
what let's establish that she does this
and she does it it's something we took
from the
from the filmation cartoons um he has a
very rich
uh history the character of he-man and
the masters of the universe but he-man
himself
mattel invents him he's just you know
he-man all the time
dc gets a hold of him they add prince
adam the secret identity because it's dc
comics that's what they do filmation
adds a few other spokes to the wheel so
he-man has had many many parents and the
mythology has
has grown over the years uh this
leans into the mythology like we don't
go like any of this is none of that [ __ ]
happened
it's all real it all happened it all
plays
this you know this is a spiritual sequel
to the
to the old tv show so the idea is
let's have this play as the next episode
you know when it got canceled
this would have been the next episode if
they were like look we're going out
anyway let's make this one for adults
and so that's what we went and did here
we have the big transformation moment
hats off
to pat and adam because in the script
you know it's like one line he raises
the sword and says the
the famous words and becomes he-man and
then turns
gringer into battle cat and then leaps
into
action and they turned it into this
gorgeous technicolor sequence
like because unlike the old cartoon
where he-man went from the form of
prince adam
who was just he-man with clothes to
he-man
our version of he-man is adam is younger
and he does not
physically resemble he-man at all so
it's more of a shazam
type of thing so he goes from being this
person to being
this powerful form the most powerful man
in the universe
according to the mattel lore uh
steven root you'll hear throughout the
series as cringer
but you won't hear him as battle cat
there's a choice we made
like where we felt like when he's battle
cat he's
battle cat he's funeral he's not like
she ain't here
scala dar like we were just like he
could talk his full head off as cringer
and steven root gives him a lot of heart
wait till you get to episode two
but in terms of battle cat we felt like
let him roar just let him roar and stuff
uh he you don't hear him right there
but the great henry rollins is going to
be the voice of triclops in the next
episode
um the fisto and and
uh clamp champ also played by two people
they haven't announced yet
they don't have any dialogue in the
first five but in the next five they do
they have their own almost their own
episode
and so uh you know i don't know if i'm
allowed to say who's playing those cats
um trap jaw just got punched by
by duncan there this is one of my
favorite look at him bam bam's a
rotor on roton and and just keeps
[ __ ] running
the most dangerous man in eternia that's
what we call him um look at that
everyone's like when they saw the t's
they're like i had that all right
bastard stories oh my god it looks just
like it
that's the idea patton adam made very
sure lovingly depict the vehicles and
like depicting the vehicles was a big
thing man bringing in the land shark and
stuff like that
again we wanted it to feel like your
childhood
and most of those toys came from mattel
most of the vehicles and whatnot so we
tried to
work them in as much as possible uh here
we get to see
he-man in glorious action just as you
remember him from back in the day
um the skelecons come from a very
rare um storyline that ran in the
british
masters of the universe comics uh but
the patton adam loved the design so boom
we brought them in
um this is one of my favorite bits man
when they uh like it's literally written
into the script
um when uh you know uh the the horse
goes ape [ __ ] and [ __ ]
man at arms comes over and punches it in
the face um
that's you know an homage to conan
without whom we don't ever get to
have this show whatsoever um
so he calls him a nightmare he's like
i'll handle this nightmare
um orco uh as you'll see played pretty
much
like orco although in our telling you
know he's not as
quite as goofy or silly and stuff like
that a little just
grown up just a tiny bit but he'll grow
up even more um yeah watch this man he
gets punched in the face
i wrote that in the script it always
made me laugh i was like man in ours
punches this metal horse right in his
face
just seemed like a badass thing to do so
we're still
you know 13 minutes in this is still
very much could be
an episode of he-man and the masters of
the universe
from the 80s although granted there's
been way more violence
in this than there ever was in the
entire run of that series
so as we enter the heart of the castle
that's when the story is about to start
changing and you know it's again it
doesn't throw out everything you know
this is when the stakes get a little
higher now props to adam and pat
again um for saying when i turned in the
first script they were like
can we have a massive
he-man and skeletor fight like right now
it's like a quarter page
we want to milk it to death and you know
they're like these two
have never really gotten to fight in the
old
cartoon in the filmation cartoon so the
idea of being able to show them
crossing swords using the havoc staff
like trying to kill each
other you know they're like audiences
have wanted to see that
for years and i was like you're
absolutely right so we'll beef up
the fight in the heart of the castle um
because i you know i was in a hurry to
get to
what we're gonna get to which is the
turn i was happy to write all this stuff
because again it was like pretty much
channeling the 80s
and this is the innocence of masters of
the universe this part
of the show that we're in right now but
things
turn and that's when the show grows up
a little bit so i was like you know i
was eager to get to that because that's
where the plot kicks in and that's the
rest of the episodes
but the boys were absolutely right to be
like let them fight
let them fight and we did and you know
the fight sequence that the boys put
together is made up of things that they
brought to it things that were in the
script
things that were in other scripts like
the giant handbit
i think appears in another episode or a
script for another episode but they were
like let's bring that up that's pretty
dope
so um you know and look at that like you
know he-man punching a giant
[ __ ] skeletor fist like you ain't
gonna you ain't gonna get that in the
real world you might one day
i think this might actually grease the
gears because people will be like oh my
god this stuff plays you can make this
work for years
mattel rob david told me at mattel a lot
of people wouldn't like
invest in he-man or masters of the
universe because they were like that's
goofy
but interestingly enough marvel with
guardians of the galaxy
opened the doors for goofy to take goofy
and turn it into kitschy and fun and
more importantly for the
company profitable so suddenly because
of guardians of the galaxy that's when
they were like oh it's time
it's time to get he-man going and stuff
he-man and the masters of the universe
and a lot of people have been like where
what happened to the name how come you
took he-man's name off this is where it
turns ladies and gentlemen right here
this is the moment and it was in the
outline as well
as soon as moss man goes down that's the
end of the innocence
like that's us taking your childhood toy
we're taking one off the table and being
like and he's never coming back
but you know this being sci-fi fantasy
does anybody really die
we'll see so here we get to see skeletor
you do something you've never seen him
do before and now you see he-man bam
do something that you've never seen him
do before he
literally [ __ ] rails skeletor
right in the gut with the sword of power
they don't just fight he stabs him and
then skeletor grabs the sword and pulls
it in deeper
how metal is that and he man's like what
the [ __ ]
and this is where we get deep into
mattel
lore so we're going to introduce the
notion of the orb of power
and the orb of power you like was
he'll tell you if you listen to skeletor
he's going to tell you that came out of
like the mo 2 mini comics
so you know we didn't reinvent the wheel
here we honored what came before
and the history of castle grey skull you
know people always look at all castle
grace gold looks metal as [ __ ]
castle grey skull according to mattel
lore is a false facade as we see right
there
um as the skull even the skeletons are
[ __ ] freaked by it there's the palace
of wisdom
it was always the palace of wisdom
castle grayskull
is an illusion like a magic spell
underneath it's the gorgeous palace of
wisdom
that goes right back to the motu mini
comics as does the orb of power
and so we use that orb of power as our
big macguffin as to like uh oh the orb
of power is shattered
now what and then we freeze there's a
there's a line right here i'm so proud
of when she says
but time is stronger than magic um i
love that line and i you know for you
for the two years of working on this i
was like oh my god that's the best line
i've ever written
now i'm sure i probably heard it
someplace else it just worked its way
into my subconscious because that line
is too [ __ ] good to just come from my
head
i write [ __ ] like snoochy boochies not
like time is stronger than magic
um which is a cool notion because that
means magicians can die
you can wield magical powers but like
you can't fight [ __ ]
time at the end of the day so here is
where we get into exposition land and
set up a lot of what our whole series is
predicated on
as you see teal is like wait a second
what do you mean
like she's about to say it i think in
this form
because tila never knew that prince adam
and he-man were the same person so
they still haven't even told her the
sorceress knew sorcerers knows a lot
about tilo that she's never shared
man at arms knew cringer knew orco knew
but tila who
ma who prince adam was protected by hila
protect
tila protected prince adam and he-man
who fought side by side by
with teela the in every episode um and
you know tiller who sometimes saved his
life and he saved steal his life
he never told her who he was so
this is a kind of magical moment this is
a total kid's imagination moment
moment that goes back to me watching the
show in the 80s i was like if he's
already he-man and he had the sword
what would happen if he said the magic
words again like you know because
there's a way to
undo it he says let the power return and
then he becomes prince adam again
but what if you doubled up like what if
you hit it again
man you're already he-man you're like
bought a power of grace gone you get
blasts again
then what happens so that's where this
notion comes from and the idea of
the sword being a conduit him being the
spark
and perhaps like the sword can conduct
all the magical energy that's breaking
out of the orb and
is going to destroy the whole [ __ ]
universe and we get to see
both tila and skeletor for the first
time
seeing that he-man is this boy he's been
prince adam all this time
and that's one of my favorite moments
where skeletors like he's just a boy
and that boy is holding all the power of
the universe in his bare hands it says
so much
about adam there's this beautiful moment
coming up here where tila realizes
what's about to happen
so does adam adam looks over his
shoulder chris wood gave us this little
like scared intonation
and then that's it man we take he-man
out of the equation
now uh some people are like hey the
internet said that and you said it
wasn't true that's not true
somebody on the internet said i heard
that the he-man the masters of universe
show
is uh tila is a better he-man than
he-man
and she gets the sword and that you know
uh
tila's got a girlfriend and i said that
is patently untrue that's untrue
and i still maintain that and i maintain
that this is a he-man story this whole
thing is a he-man story
so even though he-man seemingly
dies wink-wink in episode one kids like
don't forget
we all loved zack snyder's justice
league and that was about
superman and superman wasn't even in it
until like the last 20 minutes or
whatever the [ __ ]
we don't do that but you know we
basically took a very superpowered
individual and said what happens
if what happens if he pulls out of that
universe what happens to all the people
around him here
you're seeing an idea leaned heavily
into by ted biaselli he was like
i always thought that marlena knew king
randor didn't know
marlena did know so he's like when this
moment happens she has to break down
like she's like oh my god we didn't just
lose the champion we lost our son
and that created like wonderful moment
for like randor to feel betrayed
this is where we're grown up not only
when we burn down moss man do we take
the turn
everybody's talking like a grown-up now
it's no longer about friendship and you
know let's get together and like you can
help others and patience and
all the moral lessons from the 80s now
they're all acting like adults hurt
betrayal if randor is going like i'm
going to have this guy
executed he's about to turn and [ __ ]
scream at him listen to this he's just
belting it out at duncan man of arms the
most dangerous man in attorney
duncan could smoke this fool with a look
he wouldn't even have to pull out a
laser and stuff
but duncan's like roll has always been
about fealty to the crown we play that
a great deal in our storyline and stuff
so
this is the moment where tila loses it
where she's like i am
done uh the idea that i've been lied to
this whole time
and now she's got to carry this for the
rest of her life
that her best friend and the person she
loved literally just lied to her face
and he never got a chance to tell her
why
never got a chance to make it right
she's got to deal with the loss of her
friend
uh the loss of a loved one and then deal
with all the anger she feels about so
you could as you could see
she's launching this anger at everybody
and the show
the characters in this moment are
struggling to bring the show back to
what you remember from childhood like no
in fact when they leave orco will be
like come on tila we can get through
this like we always do
but tila has now seen the truth tila has
had
a revelation that like her whole life is
based on [ __ ]
magic all these legends everything she's
fought for
she's offered her life for these things
she's done throws down the tiara has
that wicked head of hair
and out she goes man there's orco
pleading for her to stay
this is where the story essentially
begins and now it's all about how do you
make things right that's all you ever do
in a show right right there you could
hear
alan oppenheimer the great alan
oppenheimer
speaking as skeletor when he he does our
mossband the voice of moss man
so when he was there i was like alan can
you give me your best
skeletor you know because his voice he's
older so he can't quite do it the same
and he's generally unwilling to do it
for that reason but i was like can you
give us your
your best uh you know uh
skeletor voice of like he-man finally
killed skeletors so you can hear it in
there
um the music by bear mccreary that
you're hearing
absolutely wonderful we're not worthy of
music this good
feels like it should be done for a
feature but bear felt that he's like you
guys treated this material so seriously
i couldn't not treat it equally as
seriously he went out and hired an
orchestra
overseas to actually compose the score
not just doing it on like a synthesizer
or whatever
so there you see we're at the end
powerhouse animation logo the mattel
television logo
powerhouse the good kids at powerhouse
that outdo themselves with every episode
and i'm here to tell you
the story outdoes itself with every
episode as well
i firmly believe that episode two is
better than episode one i firmly believe
episode three is better than episode two
i firmly believe episode four better
than three and five is better than them
all
and wait until you get to six six is one
of my favorite things that ever happened
in media
um seven takes you on a magic car bro
eight we
we were able to escalate with every
episode
to make it better there's no slow
episode there's no like ah [ __ ] this
noise
it's all woven into the tapestry of this
giant epic adventure
and the adventure has just begun man so
we took the board
we played the board the way you know it
see everything is exactly where he left
it
and then we took out one very essential
element and now we get to see
what happens to eternia when
you know their champion
is no longer or is he
i guess we'll find out the more we watch
hopefully you've enjoyed
uh this commentary track for masters of
the universe revelation
uh episode one um i'll be back
with the other writers of egypt because
even though there are other writers like
i
it's all mine i came up with the whole
story so i'm deeply invested in this
um but boy oh boy the people that i'm
gonna be sitting next to
they took decent ideas and turned them
into absolute magic
there's a reason the scripts get better
with each episode even though i wrote on
every episode that's what you do a story
editor
show runner and stuff but still like
bringing in all these other wonderful
talents who you're gonna meet
you'll see how what a rich world we've
made
uh okay kids so masters of the universe
is back um you know people were like how
come i didn't call the e-man because
jokey man out of it
no because he-man and the masters of the
universe is owned by
filmation which is owned by universal uh
mattel
owns masters of the universe that was
the original line of the toys in 1981
tv show is on what 83 or something like
that so that's when it becomes he-man
the master of the universe and that
iteration is owned by somebody else not
the company that i've worked for
not the company that was involved with
revelation at all so based on that
you know that title was not accessible
to us but the point
that mattel made when i got the job
because i was like hey man man he-man
and they were like yes he-man but
and these were my marching orders from
the people who sell
toys my friend they were like yes he-man
but we have a rich
bench of characters that we want there
was a reason it was called
masters of the universe you know rob was
like filmation added he-man and
to the title later but like masters of
the universe allows you to play with
everybody not just
focus on the one character so that was
those are my marching orders going in
from tell television and
that's why when i was like all right
here's the idea for the story a story
where like we take our main guy
out of the focus for a moment or two and
you get to see
everybody else you get to grow those
characters you get to
well make new figures as well so uh
there it is we're off to the races man
i'm so happy
to share this with you i've been sitting
on this for like two [ __ ] years man
that's the only downside with animation
takes like so long before you can
share stuff and also the downside
working on something you don't own
so you know if i'm working on a json bob
thing i'll spoil a whole [ __ ] thing
long before you see it
i'm working for somebody else they're
like you shook your book and mouth so i
haven't been able to say anything until
the show drops now that the show is
dropped
so come back next episode where i'll be
sitting down
uh with dia and we'll watch episode 2
of masters of the universe revelation
only on netflix
go watch it right now go watch it again
without me it'll be much more enjoyable
as my wife says this
is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga
has a 10 year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
jay and sam bob get old i'm kevin smith
[Music]